l' affaire grégory donc en cours de
rebondissements en coups de théâtre
depuis quelques jours derniers épisodes
en date cet après midi à paris
marie-ange laroche sa soeur muriel et
leurs frères entendus près de trois
heures à la brigade criminelle pour
avoir été trouvé en possession d'armes
à leur entrée au palais de justice de
paris décidément de plus en plus
rocambolesques jean françois grégoire
19h05 mariage la roche
muriel bolle et son frère lucien kit que
le palais de justice lieu de transit
d'un après-midi finalement passés au
quai des orfèvres arrivé vers 15 heures
au palais de justice de paris
le clan la roche étaient initialement
venus pour être entendu dans le cadre de
leur dépôt de plainte contre x pour
violation du secret d'instruction suite
aux récentes déclarations du juge simon
mais lors du contrôle systématique à
l'entrée du palais les gendarmes
découvrent que l'homme et les deux
femmes sont armés de pistolets d'alarmé
pour marie-ange et muriel un couteau à
cran d'arrêt pour lucien bref passage
dans le bureau du juge moati puis
direction la criminelle pour
interrogatoire
explications nous avons peur il te
policiers marie-ange laroche
c'est pour ça que nous sommes armés cet
incident traduit une situation
extrêmement déplorable
concernant l'acta psychologique de nos
clients et sont désespérés et qui vivent
dans la terreur depuis la mort de
bernard laroche trois heures de procès
verbal pour un acte non prémédité mais
qui pourrait entraîner une comparution
pour port d'armes prohibées
rhj a rendez vous avec la justice le 10
novembre pour la plainte contre x
une convocation sans armes cette fois